All of show developer Peter Lenkov's reboots
of previous TV shows, including "MacGyver,"
"Magnum P.I.," and "Hawaii Five-0," share
the same fictional universe known as the "Lenkov-verse,"
and have been substantial hits for their parent
network CBS.
However, the Lenkov-verse has seen a great
deal of controversy over the years.
In 2017, regular "Hawaii Five-0" cast members
Daniel Dae Kim and Grace Park left the series
over a salary dispute, given how they were
reportedly paid 10-15% less than series leads
Alex O'Loughlin and Scott Caan.
Then in 2020, Lenkov was fired from the three
shows by CBS after multiple claims that he'd
fostered a toxic work environment, as well
as allegations that he was abusive and manipulative
on sets.
"MacGyver" concluded in 2021 after five seasons,
and "Magnum" is still on the air as of 2022.
Much of this, of course, is behind-the-scenes
stuff, and even really tense sets have been
known to produce entertaining works.
On the whole, "Hawaii Five-0" is precisely
the kind of action-packed police procedural
drama that's an easy fit for a multiple-season
run.
However, that doesn't mean the show is entirely
devoid of problematic moments in front of
the camera.
In fact, all those off-screen problems might
have meant that nobody noticed how bleak and
off-putting a particular Season 10 plot is.
Let's take a look at the "Hawaii Five-O" scene
that the fans think went too far.
In episode 14 of Season 10, Danny meets an
attractive woman at a bar, and they hit it
off.
However, as they head home together, the pair
end up in a crash after Danny is forced to
swerve to avoid an oncoming car.
The woman is badly injured, and they're in
a remote area without cell reception.
Dramatic and sad scenes ensue, and in the
end, she passes away before help arrives without
ever telling the devastated Danny her name.
"What's so funny?"
"I got the luck like you said.
I meet the girl of my dreams and we get in
a car accident."
The plot is definitely sad, but it arguably
feels off in a number of ways.
Chief among them is the fact that the entire
thing seems to run against Danny's characterization
— which is saying something, considering
that the show's had time to explore the character
for years and years at this point.
While Danny is incredibly faithful to his
friends, he's also a rather melancholic and
reserved figure who's incredibly unlikely
to open the creaky armor of his sarcastic
exterior for a new acquaintance.
As such, it seems out of character for Danny
to bond with someone so quickly — and unfair
to have the character go through another loss
after the murder of his partner and a messy
divorce.
This may be one of the reasons why some fans
feel the story is contrived.
One "Hawaii Five-0" subreddit user pointed
out Danny's out-of-character behavior, and
felt that the storyline only happened as,
quote, "another go for Peter Lenkov to punish
the character."
As a whole, the episode is clearly not a fan-favorite
episode.
In fact, with its comparatively meager 6.8
IMDb user rating, it's far and away the lowest-rated
episode in the entire "Hawaii Five-0" Season
10.
Apart from the way the episode both portrays
Danny in a strange way and puts him through
the emotional wringer by introducing a potential
love interest and taking her away within the
span of a single episode's run time, viewers
have pointed out other issues in the episode,
as well.
Multiple IMDb user reviews concurred that
Danny's behavior is off here, and not only
in the dramatic death scene.
One User pointed out that his first aid skills
are completely wrong, and even said that he
directly contributes to the woman's fate with
his clumsy attempts to save her.
What's more, another user noted that the terrifying
incident is more or less forgotten after the
episode is over, since, quote, "the police
did not investigate or judge the driver and
[they] never mention it again."
"Come on, come on, come on.
Come on!
Somebody!."
While Scott Caan gets a chance to flex his
dramatic muscles here, his character's big
scene in this episode has clearly bothered
many people — as has a whole bunch of other
stuff surrounding it.
All in all, definitely not the finest hour
of "Hawaii Five-0."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
awkward television moments are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.